jean marc jancovici
pour le spécialiste de la transition
énergétique que vous êtes si je vous dis
urgence climatique
pour vous la catastrophe qui vous
inquiète le plus paradoxalement c'est la
grande difficulté qu'il ya à faire
comprendre les contours du problème à
ceux qui doivent décider de quelque
chose les électeurs
les élus les gens qui travaillent dans
le monde économique les enseignants sur
tout le monde en fait si je vous dis
agence climatique la solution est là pas
une agir pour préserver la stabilité du
climat en fait rejoint d'autres
objectifs environnementaux et c'est agir
en comprenant que sans planète terre n'y
a pas de pib il n'y a pas d'humanité il
n'y a pas de paye a pas de justice etc
et c'est savoir mettre partout dans nos
décisions en particulier économiques
l'environnement à sa juste place
si je vous dis agence climatique votre
engagement de citoyen mon engagement de
citoyen c'est que ça fait 20 ans que
j'essaie de gagner ma vie en occupant du
problème j'espère enfin non plus
exactement
j'espère qu'un jour je me retrouvais au
chômage c'est là que le problème sera
derrière nous ou en tout cas au chômage
du métier que je fais actuellement mais
enfin tant que le problème est là oui ça
va continuer merci jean marc jancovici